according to last week's survey most  voyeur most voters were disappointed by  legislators inability working together  on key issues or no error so the part  that feels fishy to me is is right  around here because we're talking about  legislators inability to work together  working to get limit this should be the  whole thing according to last week's  survey most voters were disappointed by  legislators inability to work to work  together on key issues right what are  they complaining about the inability to  work together they're not complaining  about inability working together that  doesn't this doesn't even actually make  any any any grammatical sense I don't  even know what inability working  together even means they're trying to  say inability to work together on key  issues so it's definitely part see right  over here where we have the error